[Música]
bienvenidos a esta charla les voy a
contar en 15 minutos cómo la humanidad
fue descubriendo la evolución del
universo
el universo
la cosmovisión era que el universo era
estático por los siglos de los siglos
que fue siempre igual no tuvo nacimiento
y es no hacer nada eso fue hasta el año
1929 cuando edwin huggel descubre y
descubrió que las galaxias se alejan de
nosotros el universo no es estático es
dinámico el mismo edwin google descubrió
las galaxias en 1923 o sea nosotros
vivimos en la vía láctea con 100 mil
millones de estrellas pero aislados de
este grupo de estrellas hay otras
galaxias andrómeda etcétera
entonces en 1929 de repente el universo
no es estático es dinámico
y si ustedes ven la ecuación de
evolución del universo es este que
describe
el lanzamiento de este objeto
si dibujo aquí la altura
y el tiempo
el objeto
aumento de altura llegó a un máximo y
volvió a caer
pero si yo lanzo esto con mayor
velocidad puede ser
tengamos esto
o sea el objeto se aleja de la tierra en
forma indefinida
y ahí el caso límite intermedio
en qué
la velocidad va atendiendo a una
constante
las ecuaciones de este lanzamiento son
las mismas del universo de newton y
también coinciden con la relatividad
general de einstein y cuando en mil
en 1916 einstein publicó sus ecuaciones
de la relatividad general
freedman alexander fridman la resolvió y
encontró estas tres alternativas para el
universo
lo que observo google es que las
galaxias se alejan y lo que hoy
conocemos como ley de google es que una
galaxia que está al doble de distancia
se aleja con el doble de velocidad
o sea que si uno extrapolase a el pasado
todas las galaxias estuvieron juntas al
mismo tiempo es como una granada las
esquirlas más rápido hoy día están más
lejos y las esquirlas más lentas
están más cerca y si extrapolamos al
pasado encontramos una explosión que se
la conoce como ustedes saben cómo el
big-bang y eso fue una revolución en
física y el primer afectado fue einstein
porque cuando fridman encontró estas
soluciones y ninguna estática einstein
dijo obviamente todos sabemos que el
universo es estático mis ecuaciones
están mal y pasó diez años modificando
la relatividad general y le agrego lo
que llamamos una constante cosmológica
para tener una solución inestable pero
estática y ahí fútbol destruyó todo
encontrando que se expande el universo y
einstein dijo he cometido el error más
grande de mi vida y borró la constante
cosmológica y esa borrada fue su error
más grande
entonces este universo tiene energía
igual a 0 o sea la energía cinética
positiva igual a la energía potencial
negativa y esto tiende a una constante
tiende a velocidad cero esto aquí es la
distancia entre cualquiera dos galaxias
en cambio aquí arriba la la energía es
positiva o sea que la granada que
explotó tuvo más energía y las esquirlas
que se atraen gravitacionalmente y no
detienen la expansión en cambio en el
otro caso tenemos energía
negativa o sea
la granada explota las esquirlas salen
volando pero como se atraen entre sí se
detiene la expansión y buell vuelve a
colapsar yo llegue al ecuador en el año
72 y lo primero que hice fue ir a la
escuela politécnica nacional y dar esta
conferencia y dije que hoy
hoy estamos aquí aquí o acá
y cómo sabemos cuál es el futuro del
universo la manera de saberlo es medir
la densidad del universo si la densidad
es mayor que la crítica la ex para
expansión se detiene y vuelve a colapsar
si la densidad es menor que la densidad
crítica no hay suficiente materia para
detener la expansión y sigue
expandiéndose para siempre y yo les dije
en el año 72 a los estudiantes de la
escuela politécnica nacional que la
densidad medida tenía un error
experimental que iba desde la mitad
hasta el doble la mitad hasta el doble
de la de la densidad crítica así que les
dije no les puedo decir el futuro del
universo pero en 5 años si les voy a
decir me equivoqué han pasado desde el
72 40 y
46 años pero ahora si les voy a decir
dejen contarles que en el 72 el universo
tenía tres posibles destinos
muerte luminosa y caliente
y una vida eterna oscura y que va
atendiendo a 0 grados kelvin oscura y
fría y el caso intermedio de cero
energía ahora en la física la comunidad
se dividió en tres los seguidores de
einstein que decían que debe haber
suficiente materia en el universo para
detener la expansión porque si el
universo nació pues tiene que morir y lo
bonito de
del caso rojo es que la materia cierra
el espacio sobre sí mismo el universo es
como la superficie de tres dimensiones
de una esfera en cuatro dimensiones el
volumen del universo es
finito y si yo camino para allá igual
que colom puedo regresar por acá y las
ecuaciones de einstein no necesitan
condiciones de bordes entonces esos eran
los seguidores de einstein pero los
astrónomos estaban aquí arriba porque no
encontraban suficientes densidad en el
universo para
detener la expansión y los teóricos
decían porque la densidad no es millones
de veces mayor o millones de veces menor
que la densidad crítica porque sólo un
factor 2 eso no puede ser casualidad
porque jamás ningún físico ha ganado la
lotería
entonces los teóricos decían que debe
ser energía cero
ahora
un paréntesis hay un libro escrito por
steven weinberg titulado the first three
minutes que está en la biblioteca de la
universidad que relata lo que pasó en
los primeros tres minutos y 46 segundos
cuando se formó el helio es apasionante
como la universidad descubrió eso pero
yo quiero acercarme más al presente solo
tengo pocos minutos así que les voy a
decir que en el en los años 1990 en esa
década dos grupos uno de permutar en el
hemisferio norte y otro es
en nueva zelanda en el hemisferio sur
estudiando supernovas no sólo ven la
expansión del universo con la ley de
google pero esa expansión es acelerada
ahí casi se me paraliza el corazón
cuando escuché eso porque no es ninguna
de estas tres soluciones en la
naturaleza es mucho más interesante que
toda la ciencia ficción a mí me aburre
la ciencia ficción entonces
el universo de repente se acelera su
expansión ahora eso no me lo creí así
que agarré a un estudiante de la
universidad de los andes en bogotá y nos
estudiamos todas las supernovas y
llegamos a la misma conclusión en forma
estadísticamente muy marginal pero el
universo experimentalmente se acelera
no me pregunten a mí por qué porque yo
no hice el universo a quien tienen que
preguntar a quien tienen que preguntar a
santiago gangotena
entonces experimentalmente lo que sucede
es esto
y estamos aquí apenas se está comenzando
la expansión
ahora
según digital sky survey hizo un
catálogo de dos millones de galaxias y
nos pusimos a medir esta curva azul
toda esa curva sur hasta el presente ahí
exagere
y
e
einstein ya había muerto para entonces
murió en 1957 creo que hubo que volver a
poner la constante cosmológica de
einstein
entonces hay tres parámetros
cosmológicos la energía del universo o
densidad de energía del universo que es
como decir el precio del universo cuánto
pagarían ustedes por tener el universo
cuánto me falta dos minutos
tenemos la constante cosmológica
y tenemos aquí
la pendiente que
se llama h 0 inverso de h 0 es la
constante de jul
ahora las medidas más precisas de la
humanidad sobre esos tres constantes
cosmológicas la tiene la universidad san
francisco de quito
y hemos liderado
las medidas de la evolución del universo
o sea eso es algo que se hizo aquí
cruzando un puente en la otra mitad de
la universidad
mil gracias
[Aplausos]